okay so dark days the forge is amazing
oh my god this this story for real or
true alright for real and for true this
is the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth it's absolutely insane like it's
such an amazing story because what it
does is bring back a lot of characters
who have just kind of been missing in
action or the fans have wanted to see
return to the main DC landscape and so
before we get into this one of the
things that this does is this actually
opens up with Carter Hall and that's
actually a pretty big deal because
Carter Hall was the post-crisis on
Infinite Earths version of Hawkman now
when it came to the Hawkman character
and I've never really covered him
because it is an absolute nightmare
trying to cover this guy with Hawkman
back in the day really before crisis on
Infinite Earths so everything from the
1940s up to the 1980s it was an absolute
mess I mean it was just reboot and
reboot and reboot new origin new origin
it was absolutely crazy and it was
almost impossible to keep track of him
now all this was taken care of and
Hawkman volume 4 I think I want to say
Geoff Johns was the one who did it
although I wouldn't come I can swear to
that but what he basically did is they
went through all the Golden Age stuff
all the stuff that happened with Hawkman
between 1940 and you know the 1980s mid
1980s and even after the mid 1980s going
up to JSA and said consolidate all this
information clean it all up and give a
definitive origin for his character and
so what we actually have in this
particular story is the origin for
Hawkman Carter Hall as we know him and
so what this does is it actually removes
the new 52 version of himself and says
that's no longer part of the equation
this is the car hall that we know of
that we're most familiar with and what
this does is basically just kind of
again runs over the origin that Carter
Hall himself was a guy who basically
just operated out of Egypt during Ramses
I think it was and you know basically
came across this ship that was made of
in metal now we'll talk about if metal
here in a second but after this war did
you notice this quick little two-page
thing is given to us we immediately jump
to the modern day and that's one of the
things that's going to be consistent in
this story is going to be a handful of
different plot lines coinciding at the
same time but none of it's confusing
instead what we're actually going to get
when it comes to Hawkman all these
little interjections periodically but
we're basically going to see him just
kind of chiming in and telling us a
little bit more of the story the issue
with this is that we can't really like
take it in segments right like we can't
jump
the story like we did that with
Deathstroke for example the way the
story was written it was all over the
place so we split the video in half and
we actually did like one half of the
comic and then another half of the comic
and took it out of order we can't do
that here we actually just kind of have
to go through everything so this is
pretty straightforward in the sense
there's a guy by the name of dr. Madison
who is working on you know in some
secret lab based out of a volcano things
go awry
Batman responds and that man tries to
get him out now the initial response to
this is that Batman or at least initial
indication is that Batman is trying to
save this guy just because of the fact
that he's dying but the question we have
to ask is that how did that man know
about this how did that man know this
thing was even here how did he know this
guy was stuck in here aquaman responds
accordingly and of course we end up
having you know Batman and Aquaman
working together to get dr. Madison out
of there but what we also find out is
this was basically a black ops site no
one was supposed to know that it was
there no one was supposed to know that
it was via that anything was happening
here of course we also end up learning
they were mining from something and this
is why we ended up covering des titres
entire run of the new 52 Batman because
all this stuff comes back into the
equation that's why it was so important
that we cover all those things because
they all come home to roost all those
chickens come home to roost and so what
this does is it really highlights the
idea the Batman's hiding something now
again this is cool because this is
Snyder and everybody really going back
to the roots of what makes that man who
he is historically speaking Batman's
always been this cloak-and-dagger
enigmatic kind of character in the sense
that after crisis on the federer's going
into the release of the Dark Knight
Returns that changed the tone of Batman
prior to the Dark Knight Returns Batman
wasn't like a carefree happy-go-lucky
guy but he wasn't nearly as dark as he
was during that story in the old
original you know Batman stories like a
really really old first appearance of
Detective Comics but first time he got
his own solo series he was pretty dark
where that was par for the course it
wasn't out of the ordinary
Batman killed people he hung a guy from
the batwing once Superman killed people
or at least let people die that was not
uncommon but when the shift began that
you know began to happen for characters
in the sense that stories were getting a
little more upbeat the characters are
being a little less dark Batman followed
that trend is started moving to the
point where he wasn't really dog now
we've talked about that before in terms
of the basis behind that you know the
whole idea of the you know comics code
Authority and how Batman almost got
canceled we've talked about those kinds
of things before but with regards to the
character of
explain himself it wasn't until the Dark
Knight Returns that he went from you
know his original appearances being dark
going to more of an upbeat character and
then going back to being dark again a
lot of it was because the Commish code
was being phased out so it was fun
you know DC could get away with a lot
more stuff in the late 1980s going into
the 1990s and they could doctor in the
60s and 70s but with regards to the
character of Batman moving towards this
darker element he became a lot more
brooding he became a lot more sinister
in terms of you know him hiding things
from the Justice League that was really
fleshed out in jl8 our battle of course
they cover that story you'll find that
link down in the description the tower
Babel basically revealed the idea that
Batman had these protocols more or less
or it was how to defeat the different
members of the Justice League should
they ever go awry under normal
circumstances that wouldn't be a problem
the issue is that he never told them and
so what it did is it established the
idea that Batman doesn't trust anybody I
mean he doesn't trust the Justice League
or anything like that we knew that for a
while but it was one of those things it
was kind of concrete and set in stone
that became an intrinsic part of that
man's history that's why I JLA Tower of
Babel is such an important story as such
a lot of story by a lot of the common
book community because it's one of those
stories that defines you know Batman's
character was in DC Comics now of course
the response to Aquaman is exactly what
we would think it would be you know when
Aquaman is just kind of like this is a
Wayne Enterprises black site they're
drilling for something what's going on
here why didn't you tell me why aren't I
being made aware of this ultimately
Batman just kind of dodges the question
just sort of ignores things and so what
we do is we actually take up with the
Green Lantern's now keep in mind this
really kind of coincides with what's
going on in Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's right now so remember what how
did you run in the Green Lantern's well
that title first picked up you know
coming out of the events of Justice
League dark side war even during the
whole new 52 run following the events of
Flashpoint
what we knew was that the other planet
OA which was traditionally the home
planet of the guardians of the universe
had basically been destroyed now this
went into a whole litany of events which
we're covering on Sunday you know with
regards to the entire run of Geoff Johns
Green Lantern going into the new 52 -
big reboot and all that kind of good
stuff but it basically left the Green
Lantern's having to take up residence on
Mogo who's essentially just a giant
Green Lantern planet that's really all
he is but it's really cool but that's
really all he is but what this is doing
is basically grabbing all these
different operas and saying they're all
reading into one singular location in
this instance they're all leading to
Batman because Hal Jordan is actually
sent on a mission by the Green Lantern's
to go investigate something that's going
on at Wayne Manor now of course this
brings how Jordan in direct relation to
Duke Thomas and Duke Thomas is one of
those weird characters that just really
hasn't been crushed out yet he was a
character that we saw with regards to
Scott Snyder's initial Batman run during
the events of a in game I think it was
and Duke Thomas's parents were subjected
to the Joker toxin and Batman basically
had to grab him and whisk him away but
the difference here is that historically
speaking
Batman jumping in and saving some kid's
life if that kid is given special
attention then we know that kid's going
to become the next Robin and that was
the case Duke Thomas received a lot more
screen time so to speak in the comic did
anybody else that Batman had saved and
so we knew that he was going on you know
gonna go on to play a role of course he
played a major part in the story we are
Robin this sort of a teenage vigilante
team operating within the realm of
Gotham City but going into DC rebirth
and the launch of all-star Batman Duke
Thomas was rolled over into the title
and all we knew was that Batman was
quote-unquote
trying something different but we have
no idea what that means we know the Duke
Thomas was not Robin he's not going to
be a Robin it's something different in
its entirety we don't know if he's going
to be a replacement you know we don't
know if he's going to be an equal to
Batman we have no idea what it means for
his character we just know that he's
effectively operating alongside Bruce
Wayne now of course the other half of
this is that we end up learning that one
of the reasons why Hal Jordan has been
sent on this mission is because of the
fact that there's basically a secret
entrance to a cave below the Batcave now
again this is secrets and revelations
these are things that we've never seen
before and it's really cool because this
adds the sort of mystery and intrigue to
the character of Batman and it's a
really interesting concept when it comes
to his character and the reason why is
because it tells us Batman's got secrets
if secrets have secrets because the
secrets of his secrets have their own
secrets like it's crazy you know it's
just this constantly falling thing and
that's what made scott snyder is such a
good writer with the beginning of Batman
in the new 52 but all those stories we
covered because it was one of those
things worse like when you think that
you know everything suddenly you learn
something new and that's why this is so
cool is because it tells us there's so
much going on with the Batman landscape
that's been hidden from us now jumping
back to Carter Hall gently back to
Hawkman what
doing is we pick up with just a little
bit of a discussion with regards to him
and the concept of implemental and
that's why I wanted to hold off on this
though but I want to wait until we got
to this section of the story to talk
about this when it came to the idea of
Hawkman because of the fact that he
didn't change so often over the years
one of the things that Jeff Johnson and
those guys did is they basically rolled
in to the notion the idea of what
Hawkman was about in terms of how they
could justify his appearances back in
the 1940s and in the 1980s and so what
they did is they fed into the existing
idea of Hawkman and his reincarnation
now that's something that was already
established it wasn't a brand new thing
it was already you know built up what
Johnson them did was just clean all that
stuff up and what we ended up learning
was that with regards to Carter Hall and
forced him operating his crew through
that during his time in Egypt he had
come across in metals not knowing what
it was but where he was stabbed by an it
metal blade alongside shayera I think it
was I remember she was stabbed or not
essentially what happened is that
instead of dying he would just go to
this process of reincarnation and
presumably for eternity he would face
off against his arch-nemesis alongside
Hawkgirl that went on in terms of a
Carter actually donning the Hawkman
mantle that didn't happen until the
1940s and the reason why is because of
the fact that with him as a character he
was going through and he was just dying
and then being reborn and dying and
being reborn that was his life he would
just die and then he would reincarnate
in a new body it was a sort of irony
just because of the fact that for him he
never really believed in an afterlife he
always believed when people die that's
it there's no moving on to eternal
splendor or anything like that his soul
would be confined to the earthly plane
for all eternity
and so because of this we ended up
having this scenario where once he was
basically reincarnated in the 1940s he
picked up the name of Carter Hall and
then adopted the mantle of Hawkman after
harkening back to his memories during
the time of ancient Egypt when he had
seen this that crash-landed it had
this sort of a hot crust on it so that's
really where that whole mantle that
whole name came from now following that
what we ended up learning is that he was
effectively obsessed with the idea of
info metal that he just began going
through and collecting all these
different artifacts everywhere that he
could find them but the problem with
this was that he didn't know anything
about it all he knew is that for
whatever reason instumental seemed to
radiate this kind of energy that nobody
seemed to be able to figure out and what
does does it
it feeds into the nature of metal in the
realm of DC Comics in metal is one of
these materials that DC had where they
were just like well you know just it's a
metal that lets people do whatever they
want to do at any particular point in
time it allowed people to fly by
negating gravity if somehow had magical
properties but it was never fleshed out
it was this super ambiguous a magnetic
thing that nobody ever understood or
nobody ever really grasped how it is
that it functions
it's like Thor's hammer right like for
years and years and years it was well
you know only those who are worthy can
wield Thor's hammer what makes them
worthy because bad guys have picked it
up and good guys have picked it up the
whole idea was that it kind of you know
was ambiguous it was weird there was no
real explanation but we're Jason Aaron
fleshed out to hammer for Scott Snyder
it's fleshing out the nature of metal
with regards to Batman matter I guess
Dark Knight metal so that's why this is
such a cool in such an interesting story
because we're getting this explanation
on the super ambiguous obscure aspect of
DC Comics that has apparently been
intertwined in everything now the other
half of this is that again we start to
see the return of characters that we
haven't seen for quite some time or have
simply just kind of cut them and
shuffled off to no-man's land a perfect
case of this is a guy by the name of
Michael Holt also known as mr. terrific
now mr. terrific was well he's been
around for a long time
but he was a guy who was basically
established as being like the third
smartest man in the DC Universe for long
standing DC comic readers that's a
well-known fact they don't really need a
whole lot of explanation about that so
what really kind of guide this for a lot
of the new folks mr. terrific is one of
these guys who's super genius and he
doesn't have any powers unto himself
instead what he has is like 14 PhDs and
like his own tech company and he's like
a self-made man but he also has this
nanotech mask in the shape of a team or
at least as close as you can get to the
shape of the team while also guarding
his entire face but he also has these t
spheres I think is what they're called
and the t spheres serve a wide array of
different purposes holographic
projection and all different kinds of
things but mr. terrific is one of the
guys that you want in your corner when
it comes to being intelligent and
accessing different areas the reason for
this is because of the fact that one of
the benefits of his mask is hiding
himself from electronic surveillance his
ability to basically access different
areas without being detected
makes him essential in a lot of ways for
black ops work and so again what is
intelligence with his ability to access
through
areas what Batman had been doing is he
had actually shuffled them off to
earth-2
now the reason why this is important is
because of the fact that mr. terrific
was one of a handful of characters or
minor characters anyway that received
their own solo series during the start
of new 52 the issue was that it was
extremely poor selling I mean it didn't
sell hardly anything like I don't even
know if it broke 20,000 copies about
20,000 issues but because of that DC
basically cancelled it and they had its
character sent off by sending him over
to earth to basically a line of stories
and took place in a different universe
in DC Comics kind of a counterpart to
the new 52 main universe now the reason
why this is important is because it gave
mr. terrific kind of a world of play but
earth 2 was really kind of no-man's land
just because of the fact that the new 52
iteration of it in the beginning it was
a good story but the traditional
superheroes that we were used to were
nowhere to be seen
that's so the revamp versions that we
saw during new 52 just weren't really as
good as the classic versions that we saw
you know back before the new 52 happened
and so because of that a lot of people
looked at the idea mr. terrific and said
okay he's basically been sent off to the
cornfields we'll probably never see or
hear from him again once the earth 2
line of stories get cancelled the other
half of this is we actually learn the
reason why he went to universe was
because he was effectively a spy for
Batman and the reason why he was a spy
for Batman is because Batman's been
collecting artifacts Batman's been doing
the exact same thing that Carter Hall is
doing in terms of collecting in metal
now the big question we have to ask is
why is Batman collecting it in the first
place well what we end up doing is we
end up finding out and this little tale
bit of a conversation between a Bruce
Wayne and mr. terrific that Bruce Wayne
basically makes this statement and
saying it's time to let him out this
person we don't really know it is who
he's talking about until he and mr.
terrific enter a voltage source and we
find out it's Plastic Man now Plastic
Man Patrick O'Neil was a really
interesting character he basically got
like a reboot in Justice League
International number one what kind of a
reader not really a Justice League
International number one he was
referenced as being part of the Justice
League international team Jael I was
designed to be more of like a like two
Justice League but more accessible in
the sense that they weren't really like
cloak-and-dagger they weren't like gods
they didn't sit in some you know cower
out in space somewhere they could
basically be controlled by the
government they wanted to bring Patrick
O'Neil in but they said he was crazy and
that's all we got we got like a panel
eventually they rebooted his Orange
as part of forever evil during Justice
League number 25 but all it really did
is say here's why this guy is Plastic
Man here's why he's elastic but this is
an instance of DC grabbing fan favorites
that have been gone from coming books
for quite some time and rolling them in
the reason why this is kind of important
though is because Plastic Man in classic
DC before the new 52 was like this
comedic relief in a lot of different
ways he was the guy that brought a
little bit of freshness some fun some
interest to the comics where you know
without him they would've been pretty
dark you know in pretty drab in a lot of
different circumstances and so it's
really just the idea that he's just been
kept in stasis been kept on ice so to
speak because the weakness of Plastic
Man being frozen for the same reason but
if you threw rubber into a fridge it
would probably break you know you could
take it out what's this frozen and
shatter it or something on those lines
but picking back up with Duke Thomas and
how Jordan is there exploring the
interior of this cave this is when we
learn everything that's been going on in
the sense of what it is that Batman's
been doing and we actually find out that
his research into you know this in metal
goes all the way back to the original
quarter bowel story remember when we
covered that original event one of the
things that we established was that the
court of owls were basically creating
towns which is to say these different
agents that would carry out their agenda
the court of owls was basically this
organization that existed behind the
scenes in Gotham City that nobody knew
about they've been around for hundreds
and hundreds of years and if somebody
stepped into the life that was trying to
work against them for somebody was
trying to change the grain of where they
wanted things to go they would send a
talent out and the talent would execute
them that was the whole basis behind the
court of Allen's rhyme beware the court
of owls that watches all the time and so
on and so forth it was a really cool way
to kind of reinvigorate the Batman
landscape but what they would do is they
would basically go through the group
Haley's Circus which is where the flying
Grayson's dick Grayson's family came
from or at least where they gained her
their their most prominence what they
ended up doing is Haley the guy who was
leading Haley's circus would basically
present what he considered to be the
most viable candidate for talent to the
court of owls and if they found it
acceptable they would install inside of
that person electrum a material that
would just sit inside of a tooth when
that person died they would be exposed
to Dionysia which would more or less
bring them back and then they would
operate as an agent of the court of owls
as a talent now Bruce Wayne figured out
what was going on and he basically saved
a Grayson from this almost guaranteed
threat but this tooth resides in the bat
cave and what we find out is
this material what the court of Alice
has been calling electrum is actually in
metal not only that there's a litany of
different things throughout the cave
that are composed of instrumental all
these different things that are out
there are all just in metal materials
and we just never ever knew the entire
time not only that how Jordan and do
Thomas stumble upon the Justice League
of America team this black ops team the
Batman's form so this tells us the
course that it presumably takes place
after the you know inaugural issue of
Justice League of America rebirth number
one so again they're basically learning
all these different things now something
to point out is they're basically
receiving all this information from some
disembodied voice from some third party
that they can't explain not only that
every time how Jordan tries to use his
ring to force this person to reveal
themselves every time he tries to use
this ring to find out who this person is
that they're speaking to the ring can't
tell them there's some kind of
interference blocking the way so again
these are very cloak-and-dagger they're
very mysterious but damn it if this is
not a good story and so from this point
we jump over to Bruce Wayne and the
reborn Superman one of the most common
questions that I saw came on Twitter and
it was people asking is the Superman and
dark days is that the new 52 Superman or
the Superman reborn Superman this is the
Superman reborn Superman so this is
basically the Superman after the events
of Superman reborn that's who this says
right now that Bruce Wayne is talking to
now what we end up finding out is
somewhere along the line between the
time that the classic Superman stepped
into the role after the death of
neupogen Superman and this story Bruce
Wayne had asked him for a favor
basically asked him for a hidden vault
inside the fortress of solitude we
didn't know this happened this was
presumably something that happened off
panel the issue with this is that Batman
knew that if this vault exists
there's a key for it as well and so
where Superman created his vault for
Batman and then gave him the only key to
access it Batman threw the key into the
Sun because for him he didn't want
anybody to be able to access whatever it
was that was sitting inside this vault
and so what we end up doing is we
actually end up invoking Scott free mr.
miracle
now mr. miracle we haven't seen hide nor
hair from this guy he has vanished and
mr. miracle feeds into the whole notion
of the new gods of Darkseid and you know
New Genesis and apocalypse and
highfather all I kind of get stuck but
basically Scott free is the biological
son of hi
father but was raised by Darkseid I
remember that was a whole aspect of the
truce that was struck between the two of
them hi father and in Darkseid were just
these two representing factions of good
and evil and they were just destined to
fight for all eternity and so in order
to stage a truce this sort of I guess
universal chronicler this guy had
traveled around the universe the
multiverse and Chronicle everything he
saw storing it in his Mobius chairs I
got by the name of Metron brokered a
truce and saying that hi father and and
Darkseid will swap sons and so basically
Darkseid will raise the son of high
father and high father will raise the
son of Darkseid and so with Darkseid
raising Scott free all he really did is
just keep him in a prison cell that was
it but he just kept him locked away the
entire time now this allowed Scott free
to basically become an expert at
breaking out of locks just because of
the fact that apocalypse cut some of the
best secure locks ever because when
you're a prison planet you got to make
sure that people stay in prison but the
fact remains this led to Scott three ad
ocular mantle of mr. miracle and
basically becoming the best person in
the universe for accessing locks for
breaking in and out of virtually
anything now of course what ends up
happening is with mr. miracle being
invoke a of course unlocks this lock at
the request of Batman which is basically
revealed to us to be the Tower of the
anti-monitor from Infinite Crisis and so
I don't even know where to begin with
this piece of information I have no idea
how to explain this I don't know where
it came from
I don't know how Batman got it I don't
know the events of Infinite Crisis are
official I have no earthly clue but this
is huge because one of the things that
we talked about with Infinite Crisis was
that with that whole story alexander
luthor which we're not even going to get
into that because that goes into a whole
nother confusing kettle of beans about
the post-crisis landscape suffice it to
say the Tower of the anti-monitor was
basically used to vibrate these
frequencies and what these frequencies
would do is it would basically mimic
different universes and recreate them
like recreate these different earths and
so it was my way of the frequencies this
Sun this tower sent off that you could
recreate earth 2 or 3 and her four or
five and so I wouldn't go as far as to
say it's a reboot when I would go as far
as to say is that using this Tower
Batman could bring back universes that
have long since been gone universes that
DC got rid of when they launched the new
52 so again this is a
really really huge piece of information
because what this is doing is yet again
grabbing things from before the new 52
from classic BC and rolling them into
new 42 again the whole idea of DC
basically blending the new 52 reboot
into the classic DC Universe and
returning a lot of the things that have
been gone for quite some time and so
ultimately we end up having pal Jordan
and Duke basically open this giant vault
door that they've approached after being
told by this disembodied voice and when
Hal Jordan kind of uses to himself about
what it is that that man has gotten
himself into what we find out is that
inside this vault is the Joker Rob
Corman I don't know how he got here I
assume it'll be explained during the
events of the war of jokes and riddles I
have no idea how he got here I don't
know if he put himself here I don't know
if that man locked him away in here
I don't know like he's just here and I
have to like yeah how that happened damn
it this is a good story oh my god
did I saw this and I was just like what
my mind was blown I was I was totally
baffled I was like this is crazy because
we have no idea
well I have no idea what's going on I
had no clue I'm you guys have answered
or have questions I do not have answers
I cannot explain this comics cannot
explain this to you I don't know I have
no idea what's going on but I am excited
I am so hyped up oh my god I'm so
excited for this anyway guys if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you guys later please
[Music]